how incorrect uncharacteristic
of one of your reputation show
immediately reminds me that werner
herzog is no longer going to be playing
a character in it and for making me sad
it gets a sin a bunch of logos that tell
me that i'm watching a star wars
property
in case i already didn't know yo i know
we need to see this wretched hive of
scum and villainy but can we get on with
it this walk is taking longer than sir
lancelot's run-up to swamp castle
oh look a banksy oh let's get ready
to gomorian
[Music]
also i'm pretty sure this fight sequence
is only here because john favreau has a
boxing ring boner and far be it for me
to criticize another person's boner but
really means all of the rest of this
episode i'm told you know where to find
them
man they sure are able to have this
conversation in hushed tones despite the
raging crowd all around them
cheating these scruffy-looking nerf
herders seriously try to get into a
fistfight with a [ __ ] mandalorian
despite seeing him ice all those
henchmen seconds ago
also why would anyone punch mando in his
helmet why would anyone punch anyone's
helmet it's a [ __ ] helmet
i know mando has the armor and has a few
weapons but in the previous episodes i
don't recall him being [ __ ] inspector
gadget
i've spent much time on tatooine i've
never seen a mandalorian there
i feel like we've all spent way too much
time on tatooine in this franchise
there's a ton of world out there left to
explore but yeah let's go back to luke's
boring planet again
cut me down that wasn't part of the deal
no but you did say i promise you will
not die by my hand
and i'm pretty sure that was your hand
that fired the blaster and allowed all
the wild nuts to come kill gorkuresh
what the [ __ ] is up with the score
sounds more like the ending to jingle
all the way than an episode of the
mandalorian
sorry gang come on you know he doesn't
like droids
i'm sure pelly motto might recall
mando's dislike of droids but they've
only met once and she's acting like this
is a lifetime of experiences they share
together
oh so he likes droids now will you hurt
him
give it a once-over just because ig-11
sacrificed itself in the previous
episode mando's cool with all droids now
it's like me meeting mark cuban and
deciding all rich white men are okay
i just can't get good help anymore i
don't even know who to complain
to i love amy sedaris and i appreciate
the humor in this episode
i also think that these characters
wouldn't talk like this sorry
i think the show is trying to jam in
hokey dialogue as a throwback but the
worst part of those classic movies was
the hokie dialogue
you got mos eisley most espa an upper on
this region
most pell go yeah but what happened to
most deaf i miss that guy much more than
most pell go
i have to say this is so like an old
school western that i have to take a sin
off it's comforting and exciting and
suspenseful all at the same time and for
capturing that classic feeling
remove the sin but also these townsfolk
are totally giving away the fact that
their marshall has mando armor
if they'd just gone about their business
he probably would have moved on and not
caused any trouble these town folks are
dicks to their leadership man
considering mando keeps telling everyone
he's been quested to take care of the
child
he sure does just leave it behind a lot
where it could easily be kidnapped or
killed why wouldn't he just left it with
peli motto
she's taken good care of it in the past
[Music]
okay i understand the homage to westerns
but did that sound like actual [ __ ]
spurs
play it again ain't nobody spurs on that
costume man if you're gonna go this over
the top just give him a poncho and a
cigar for
sake cue fanboys orgasms
now i figure only one of us walking out
of here
but then i see the little guy and i
think
maybe i picked you wrong assumptions
around here
i'm the one tells folks what to do
around here i'm the one tells folks to
do cliche
and do it nice and slow all sexy like
isn't it about the time that the
bartender crawls beneath the counter i
mean he's pretty much directly in the
line of fire
it's really nice of this underground
creature to make its way through town in
a straight path and right through the
center so as not to destroy any of the
buildings
also show does not have a no banthas
were harmed during this production
warning
comparisons the town was on its last
legs
it started after we got news of the
death star blowing up the second one
that is
celebrating the deaths of all those
innocent independent contractors
also what is up with this episode having
impossible conversations in extremely
loud environments
and then i was saying wait he just
noticed this
now how did he not see that giant
automobile in the distance a long time
ago
my treasure bought me more than a full
water skin it bought my freedom
but only because the miners went to the
stormtrooper school of aiming at things
and didn't shoot you in your arm
neck stomach or legs timothy bobafant
also i don't know what's more surprising
that the jaws had mandalorian armor or
that they had a helmet that fit cobb
vance so perfectly
what am i supposed to do with this
it stinks hey the tuscan raiders have
their own version of malort
i bet there's a subreddit devoted to
raider face
how do we kill it if he could speak
english while making the hand gestures
and they still understood what he was
saying then
what were all the grunts about but also
the fact that the show took the time to
hire a deaf actor to create this tuscan
sign language for raider nation is
pretty cool and worthy of a sin-off
i say it lives in there didn't cobb
already know that though he brought
mando all the way out here didn't he
this here is a mandalorian you know what
that means
oh we've heard the stories then you know
how good they are at killing but he
doesn't because he just said he's only
heard stories maybe do a little more
listening discount raylen gibbons
the crepe dragon has been peeling off
our pack animals and sometimes taking
our mining hall with it
i know this is a bothersome phenomenon
but it doesn't sound like the dragon has
been killing anyone in the town
in fact the greater threat to the
livelihoods of this town are the tuscan
raiders themselves so why is cobb
willing to risk his greatest asset in
combat to get rid of this
annoyance sure mando could kill him but
he's risking the
entire town to combat something that
isn't really the biggest threat to his
community
this tuscan raiders meets the people of
most pell go scene goes on for some time
what are you trying to blow the whole
place up nice wouldn't be a traditional
western tv episode without a protagonist
fight amongst themselves before the
final act of the show cliche
cheese and crackers there's more
unnecessary walking in this episode than
in the entirety of the lord of the rings
franchise
sure now is the best time to take a
drink of this foul juice does he even
know if it's nutritious or
up like peyote the tusks can say the
belly is the only weak spot
i guess that would be a fair assumption
but since they've never killed one of
these how do they know that
sand people yell at this dragon to wake
him up when he's peacefully hibernating
and did i miss who the actual antagonist
is here
this [ __ ] plan i'm gonna hit it no
wait we only have one shot
then maybe it would have been a good
idea to set the chargers closer to the
entrance of the cave
by the way nice job helping with this
[ __ ] operation mr being who could
probably end this evil bastard by waving
your hands a few times before multiple
people were killed
i don't think it's dead well not with
that attitude it's not let's get after
it
yes after we've stood on the sidelines
while this feudal explosive trick was
tried and failed
we can do it there he is yeah but how
how did he get from the top of the
mountain to here without any one of you
knowing
i don't know the best car armor is
impervious to the dragon goo and he
survived being swallowed by that
and this explosive work even though the
other one didn't
and i guess this is a long-winded way of
saying mando survives this
hey what a twist it's that guy and yeah
yeah i know that everyone thinks it's
boba fett because of the actor or
whatever but some of us that just watch
this show haven't
witnessed every single [ __ ] piece of
star wars history multiple times so this
isn't a twist to us
it's just confusion about why i'm
watching this random bald guy look at
the sunsets
i want to like this show i do but how
can i when clearly no one cares about a
child's eye protection
there's so much sand and wind very
dangerous
being horny i'm no expert on crash
analysis but i find it hard to believe
that the child stops rolling after a few
tumbles they were flying at top speed
shouldn't the kid be like a green
bowling ball tumbling tush over teeth 16
miles into the desert
again no expert wait
don't hurt the child considering the
crash moments ago should have
eviscerated greeny's tiny bones i don't
think exhaust pipe eyes cares all that
much about hurting things
if you put one mark on him there's no
place you will be able to hide from me
but
two marks means you could hide in plain
sight so don't ask about that because it
really ruins the threat
[Applause]
acting casual about straight-up murder
looks like uh
someone's gonna be going home
empty-handed silly peli ants don't have
hands
tarsal claws sure but hands do we have
amanda walks into a bar cliche
cause i feel like we need amanda walks
into a bar cliche
i believe amanda is strong and tough and
has a constitution score of at least
20. i do but this man has been hauling
equipment across a hot landscape for at
least 12 minutes
and i'll be damned if anyone wouldn't
immediately drop it when they arrive at
a location where lounging is encouraged
show off you cover us call this round he
said
believing anyone involved in a card game
i'm calling mandible
what's the bet 500
grabbing exact change more importantly
you bring back any of that dragon meat
and despite that hunk of meat being
nowhere on his person earlier he
surprisingly somehow
impossibly and inexplicably has meat
if you jump into hyperspace they'll die
oh
i will give all the sins back if he
drinks the lizard boba tea right now
no no no no no okay so technically that
wasn't drinking them all
but here you murderous adorable little
bastard
sleeping through your alarm carson can
you switch over to channel two
come on carl work on your subtlety how
about a code or something
it will take a moment to analyze your
ping also release the purple unicorn
that's gonna work so much better trust
me
they will not oh look a massive canyon
that can be used to outmaneuver those
who are chasing you
what a unique idea that we have never
seen before hold on
i mean thank god you told lizzy
salamander to hold on
before this she was all like wee no
hands because strapping your cargo in
during flight is apparently a man don't
pause the show everyone keeping track of
mando's weaknesses needs time to write
plummeting into ice cave slash
body check onto flight console and yeah
it's shocking when you consider all the
other damage he's taken and managed to
stay conscious
but that's a separate list
or turn on the heater what the hell are
you doing
right this is not the time for karaoke
so the
salamander frog lady grabs her precious
offspring and heads off into the frigid
cold without a clue of dangers or
direction
because that seems like the best way to
preserve your lineage
also if mando was tracking a heat source
here how would a footstep in snow
maintain heat like this
does the creature perspire some sort of
heat trapping slime and if so why would
she ever worry about staying warm in the
first place
bobbing for boba otherwise known as boba
fetch
how many spiders are too many spiders
here why wait to run
sure the frog woman isn't ready yet but
she's putting wet clothes over her wet
body so she's gonna freeze to death
anyway
she survives that
go go go back to the ship super great
advice
curious why this wasn't the instinct 30
seconds ago but hey dramatic tension
isn't as fun if we're not running from
spiders directly on our heels
rather than oh i don't know having a
pretty great lead i realize now that
when i said
fire would help that i wasn't specific i
mean actual flames mando
not pew pew weaponry firing at this
point they are surrounded by t4 rangelas
and while i want them to survive they
should be pounced upon and bitten dozens
of times over
look at them all but also the way this
show is falling into an
x-filesy monster of the week thing is
kind of amazing and continues to make
this show one of the best things out so
take your sin off the only reason i'm
sinning this moment is because it took
him this damn long to get out the
blowtorch
and yes i know i send him for not doing
it earlier and now i'm sending him again
for doing it and you might say that's
not fair
to which i would reply hey welcome to
the channel hope you enjoy your stay
and then i'm adding another one for
putting the blowtorch away again because
i can
this little is just thinking about how
to eat all these spiders and if their
flesh is as delicious after a blaster
has ripped it apart
this area should be littered now with
dead crispy ice spiders and on behalf of
the child who would eat them all ice in
you for emitting mando's climb over
their pyre
it's pretty cool that all their gunfire
hits only the tiny targets and not the
massive ship behind it
i see their lasers are set to incredible
arachnid accuracy
inner accuracy you have an arrest
warrant for the abduction of prisoner
x-6911
noice how has no one said put down your
weapon yet
for being the rescuing sword they sure
are okay with leaving people to die
don't you be fooled this little [ __ ]
is thinking about cracking off a mammoth
spider leg as a snack
because apparently to him the entire
universe is one big episode of the great
bithish baking show
or you know fly out the way the other
guys came in
i'm gonna be ticked if this show somehow
retcons this whole thing into some sort
of plot where he's actually saving these
eggs
and not eating them because honestly the
child who even after told not to
will continue to eat your babies with a
smile is exactly the kind of star wars
content i'm here for
but since i can't know for sure one
minute of stuff i've already seen
followed by another 30 seconds of
unnecessary shiny chrome logos
recrap a chrome goes starting your star
wars while orbiting a planetscape cliche
cuddling with cream of offspring soup
also show gives us the how are you even
sleeping all stars featuring child not
in a car seat clutching an aquarium of
your potential offspring and piloting a
spaceship while wearing a heavy helmet
i'm not saying any one of these wouldn't
be possible i'm just saying to calculate
the odds of all three of them happening
at the same time might require
consulting with nate silver
taking the meme lord's name in vain dank
makes the best memes
these tense moments would be much more
concerning if i weren't 100
sure that everyone survives this come up
here i need your hands
wait until you're already plummeting to
ask for assistance granted i'm not
totally aware of how cargo holds work in
this piece of junk but you'd think while
dealing with such precious cargo you
might want to find a better solution
than
vaguely leaning it against the wall
glover needs to stay back
can you do that splaining i just want to
point out that someone in this universe
knits sweaters
and somehow these spiky arms move
through the sleeve without tearing up
these perfect cable knit patterns
but seriously how is the child still in
his seat right now
he's not buckled he should be flinging
around the cockpit like a tiny yoda ball
was he born with a heavy case of magnet
ass here we go
nice and easy
[Laughter]
seriously you're going to use a walker
type machine in the water i've seen how
clumsy those are
you're one somewhat sturdy piece of
trasky and kelp away from that thing
taking a dive
also this is the angle of the ship yet
no one is mashed to the interior of the
windshield in comedic fashion
[Music]
amphibio scoop honey
where's liam over there how does he even
know which one
i mean larry lisamander could easily be
gesturing to any number of the buildings
in this direction as there seem to be a
great many options and we already know
mando doesn't speak froggies
this food delivery sphincter reminds me
considering how every planet must have
different food and water how does anyone
manage to travel without spending the
entire first week
carbonited to the toilet and are toilets
across the universe the same
that's a lot of alien butthole varieties
to accommodate grabbing a man's chowder
hose without explicit consent
if yodesh bambino has a chestburster
scene in the next episode i'm taking
back all the sins
or adding all the sins my point is
alien you ever see a mama quarter no but
i've seen a papacor make a bad pun
is it anything like that my friend
bought a 10 stroller for his kid from
target and it had those little flip
breaks on the wheels to keep it from
moving and my point is
this thing can freaking levitate so some
sort of braking apparatus to keep this
from happening shouldn't be a stretch
this car is ours how though even if you
drown him he's enclosed with a mama core
so mama core eats mando and magically
poops out intact best car
is that the plan
deus ex mandalorian uh also why has
mando pretty much turned into a fuddy
duddy i mean look at him hanging out
above water like a guy who hasn't leapt
into the mouth of a dragon with a bomb
earlier this week
how is he not diving to the bottom of
the boat to retrieve the child right now
he's [ __ ] mando man he needs no air
you do not cover your face
you are not mandalorian gatekeeping
planets with only one son
you killed my brother now
i'm gonna kill your pet jeez blue mando
group out here deus ex machinating every
five minutes like it's their job
i was hoping you would help me by creed
thing i said to my older brother to cd
shop in 1997 because i didn't have any
money somehow makes it into the show
little did i know i was building my own
prison i can lead you to one of their
kind
but first we need your help on our
mission what
before mando can move on to the next
part of his quest he needs to take on
another side quest of helping someone
who is also in need of fulfilling their
quest
this is so surprising troopers
and they couldn't hit the side of a
banfir yeah
we know troopers suck at aiming so why
is it ever tough to take anything from
them
why are you waiting for this sneak
attack plan when you could just go take
the ship
now there's nothing you do later with 50
stormtroopers on guard that you couldn't
have done now with a night watch of at
least half that
something's come up treating strangers
like grandparents a full half minute of
star wars spaceship porn
i mean i know this is star wars and
everything but do we have to watch the
entire takeoff routine
none of these strippers even pretend to
see this fog grenade and more
importantly you just wasted a good fog
grenade when they were never going to
hit you anyway
also there were at least 10 of these
morons when the grenade went off but
your heat vision is only picking up four
now
considering your sole purpose was to
hold them off how is this not something
you already did during that lengthy
watching the elevator indicators while
the tension builds cliche
this is more than i signed up for right
but really this entire fight has been
far too easy and your presence has been
largely unneeded
so we're all very disappointed in this
and we're gonna need you to mando up and
move on to the boss fight
there is something i need if i am to
rule mandalore something that was once
mine
they know where it is and soon so will i
pronoun gaming your own easter eggs
cool scene and all but you couldn't have
just rolled those things all the way
down that hall from the other side like
you did with the fog grenade earlier
take the found lane to the city of
caledon on the forest planet of corvus
there you'll find ahsoka tano tell her
you were sent by bogotan
okay but who was taking notes cause that
was a lot
thank you for watching him and not
feeding him to your quickly insanely
fast-growing tadpole child
because honestly fair's fair i haven't
seen a vehicle take this much damage and
still find its way back to life since
the herbie movies is this ship going to
develop a personality and do a reboot
with lindsay lohan in a few years called
razor crest fully loaded cause
sin i finally know where i'm taking you
but
it's gonna be a bumpy ride disney could
just cut this line into the end of every
single episode of this show
and i'm not sure anyone would even know
the difference this asset was of extreme
importance to me
this was actually an outtake from the
end of the jack reacher movie but since
werner herzog had dressed up like an
ex-imperial commander for that shoe for
some reason
john favreau decided to use it in this
show these previously on segments at the
beginning of each episode are getting so
long that at some point they're going to
be 40
of the actual show wait this is a star
wars property
did you get the wire out sure this is
[ __ ] adorable but show spends far too
much time on this gag
when we absolutely know baby yoda has no
chance of fixing this issue
not only does baby yoda survive this he
comes out completely unscathed
you know i think we need to visit some
friends for repairs of course you do
this [ __ ] series has more side quests
than red dead redemption 2.
[Music]
generic random species doing villainy
things so we can reintroduce cara dune
to everyone is generic and random
also how has the armorer's lair not been
raided before now or why hasn't marshall
haywire confiscated all the mandalorian
bounty there's apparently a mint down
there
also also how the ever loving is this
ferret
weasel slash possum still alive down
here the raid on the slayer happened at
least
weeks if not months ago so this poor
bastard should have already starved to
death before it was threatened by these
ass faces
deus ex chronica
[Music]
bringing a knife to a blaster fight this
goofball keeps shooting at the body of
his friend
instead of aiming anywhere else where he
could actually injure martial angel dust
i just want to point out that she had a
lethal weapon the entire time but just
wanted to wrestle to the point of nearly
dying which is dumb oh great it's a
remake of that racist bruce willis movie
from 1998.
just what i expected as a detour on the
way to get yodes back to his jedi
brethren
did mando even call ahead to tell them
he was coming or did they just sense a
disturbance in the force or
some bullsh wow they've been gone long
enough for grief's beard to go
completely gray
or it is just for men supply run out
looks like someone could use some
repairs
i just realized mando is like the kid
who's been at college for the past two
months and comes home with all the dirty
laundry he needs his mom to do for him
i'll get my best people on it
and luckily they happen to be sitting
right over there one of them's an
imperial spy but let me tell you he's so
good at fixing power converters that
it's worth the risk
was that a hint of romance between these
two which makes me wonder do
mandalorians have sex it's not like
they're jedi and can't distract
themselves
as long as he keeps his helmet on and
protection on his other helmet i think
he should be dtf
we're going you don't want to take a
child trust me yeah but he doesn't know
mando is gonna help them storm the base
so why dump the kids so early
unless it's only to mine some laughs out
of the macaroon theft
also amanda allows this even though the
child has been in a ton of dangerous
situations in this series
well he may even be able to help like
he's done several times already
and there just happens to be one empty
desk for the child to sit at
also this tiny town has this many kids
that are roughly the same age to fill
the class and
none of them are aliens
[Music]
this little dude gets exactly what he
deserves for eating macaroons in class
the c3 teacher unit really needs to get
control of its student population
stealing also kids but over on this side
is the problem
it's an old imperial base and this never
came up in conversation between mando
and his other mandolins during the
entire first season
mando i just want them off my planet but
how does destroying the base guarantee
that if anything it might make the
fallen empire target their sights even
more on navarro
looks like they're not even really
bothering grief and company in the town
based on this and the events from the
marshall these towns don't seem to know
who their enemy is
and who's just a nuisance they should
learn to live with also wendy didn't
give grief the clearance to call him
mando anyway
that's like someone calling me ronnie
and i did not consent to that carlos
the whole base is powered by a reactor
having an understandable conversation in
a normal voice while speeding down the
ravine in a convertible
also how do they know this does this
mean they've scouted this before and if
so why didn't they do something about it
then
sure mando helps swing things a bit in
their favor but surely there's one or
two people in town that could be just as
helpful
also also i have to ask again did they
know amanda was coming
because what if he didn't this seems
more like a set-aside adventure in case
mando came to visit
not something all that important kind of
like if your friends came to visit you
for christmas and you took them to those
lights or whatever holiday touristy
nonsense happens in your town you would
never go there on your own but if you
have visitors it's all of a sudden
something you have to do
empty base huh um they did say there was
a skeleton crew and so far this ain't
that many guards so
cool your jetpack massaholion i'm
totally sure this overhead shot of
kara's dunes adds something to the story
it's a mint trexler marauder i would say
marauder shadowing here just as a joke
but this is such obvious foreshadowing
that they might as well have literally
said
look it's our eventual escape vehicle
from this predicament and for that
obviousness this show gets an extra
three cents
oh man if they screw up this heating
core the bull rock is gonna be
pissed me yes you okay i guess i
understand why they forced the mithril
to drive them out here just as extra
punishment
but why are they trusting him to
complete a very serious mission how do
they know he knows what to do
aren't these heroes used to doing stuff
themselves there's no guardrail on this
inside jokes maybe in the fan fiction
that i'm currently working on but i
don't think disney plus is gonna allow
that stuff on one of their flagship
properties
how long do we have ten minutes give or
take a few side quests within this side
quest and honestly that's really a
ridiculous estimate considering i've
never done this before
anyway i've been meaning to ask you
about your social media comments also
running down a corridor in a star wars
property
cliche after this whole jeans guy
mistake john favreau made all of them
dressed as stormtroopers even the grip
set designers and catering staff
which sucks have you ever tried to plate
a dozen veggie burritos and pita chips
for a cast with all that armor on
guillermo del toro's the mandalorian i
don't like this
i prefer my peep shows to be much more
animated it's like they're not even
trying to activate my lightsaber
i highly doubt we'll find a donor with a
higher end count though motherflipping
midichlorians
motherflipping midichlorians mid of
[ __ ]
mother chlorians and at some point i
really do need to have someone explain
how this armor works
ah the star wars universe where everyone
can operate any vehicle by pushing a few
buttons and engaging in positive
self-talk pew pew pew
pew pew i know we always make fun of the
storm troopers being terrible with guns
but why are these two even hanging
around at this point they won't be able
to take out the marauder with two guns
and there's no one else in their general
area
no one will know they're lying if they
tell their superiors they were knocked
out or something
so this one out live another day try
papayas mad max fiery road
why wouldn't these have already taken
off why didn't they start with these
yeah we did it this stillweed celebrates
so prematurely that i half expect
marshall dune to tell him it's all right
happens to a lot of guys
what is going on back there you want to
come back here and try this be my guest
having a conversation while under attack
we're almost down
great let's bring the three heavily
armed tie fighters directly into our
peaceful village full of civilians
holy balls not only was mando able to
get the child board his ship and get in
perfect position for this attack
his heavily damaged ship was fixed in no
time
i'm sorry there's only so much
preciousness i could take before i have
to remove a sin
i did enjoy this episode but there are
so many beats that you can see coming a
mile away like this little spit-up joke
and i have to ding it
it's my job this is the way also how is
he still chomping away on those
macaroons we've seen this thing take
down an entire
frog in just a few seconds a little bit
of food should have been devoured hours
ago along with a silver sleeve
says here you're from alderaan did you
lose anyone you know when the entire
planet exploded a few years ago
any casualties to relations or was the
family on vacation in foster paradise
what do you have for me
that device has been planted as you
requested
so do they just have this guy planted on
navarro just on the off chance manda
would come to have his ship repaired
stretching your manpower pretty thin if
you're sticking spies on every possible
location he would visit and you're
hoping you've put them in the right
position
the tracking beacon has been installed
on the razor crest doesn't it seem like
tracking beacons are only installed when
it's super convenient in this universe
if there are so many of those things why
not just use them all the time
this is the way really get the sense
that this is how john favreau responds
to anyone that dares to suggest that
these previous leon segments go on for
way too long
your bravery will not be forgotten give
me a [ __ ] break mando charged the
stormtroopers sure but
as we'll see soon his best car armor can
repel a flipping lightsaber so is it
really that impressive that he wandered
into puny blaster fire to throw those
bombs a few episodes ago
is the giant bell necessary this town is
one street and a few houses
basically the size of bucks north
tennessee i think someone could really
just
shout out from the gate that someone's
coming and everyone would hear at what
point do you realize this blaster fire
is useless on someone with shiny dildos
that deflect them and why wouldn't they
try to flank her considering the frontal
assault clearly isn't working
you know i never understood why
experienced jedi don't do this force
manipulation more often it would be much
easier to take out several enemies by
felling a bunch of dead trees or
something right
seems like this lightsaber show is
honestly just showing off also
tree murder and you might say it was
already dead in which case i will pivot
to overkill
i've lost visual scan for movement you
know this is really something you should
have been doing from the start
considering your field of vision is
severely limited because of your poor
goggle choices and terrible aim
show yourself jedi why did ahsoka wait
until now to attack the village
the magistrate has been in power for a
presumably long time given the state of
the townsfolk in the environment did she
have to wait until almost
everyone was dead or suffering before
she moved on this i've been expecting
you
oh so this is why no one is shooting at
her right now because they need to talk
in which case why send out a team to
kill her in the first place let her
waltz to the wall and wax poetic about
whatever
the lives of these citizens mean nothing
to me then why are
any of them still alive what's the point
of this entire outpost if they're not
doing anything other than torturing
villagers and pruning hedges
also how is there a conversation even
happening right now when everyone is
extremely far apart and surrounded by
airborne detritus and dense fog
everyone should be yelling
surrender or face the consequences you
have one day
to decide the [ __ ] is one day gonna do
to change anything does ahsoka really
think the magistrate will have a change
of heart after sleeping on this
well if anything she's got the advantage
right now charge
amanda eventually gets pissed that baby
odes yanks's ball but why he willingly
gave it to the kid to play with back in
the first season and it doesn't look
like it's essential for the
whatchamacallit to do the thing of my
doodle
also why is he just now noticing the
ball on the lever when he's been sitting
up front for this entire journey from
navarro to corvus
also also ball shadowing amanda flew
right over the town just a few seconds
ago so why do you park all the way out
here in the boonies
especially when the first thing they do
is look for the town
this needs to stay in the ship so
obviously i'll put it in my pocket
rather than walk the 30 feet back to the
ship and put it where it belongs
not much to see out here decorvus
station turtlenecks
i find it hard to believe given what we
know about the child's appetite that he
wouldn't be jumping out of that bag and
scarfing down everything on the street
like the samples at costco
pardon me vendor he just called that
woman
vender who refers to a person by their
occupation especially if they're a
vendor that would be like someone coming
up to me and saying pardon me youtuber
and podcaster what night lives in that
castle
what's the point of these double sealed
doors when the wall is barely eight feet
tall and easily scalable
okay the guards are there but if they're
taken out this place is easy peasy to
overtake so easy that even i could do it
i mean i can't right now because i'm
waiting for my pot pie to cool and then
i have to take the crust off and
then i separate it out and eat the
turkey first but you know later maybe
you are a mandalorian i mean what gave
it away
pure best car i've played enough video
games to know the tells of a boss fight
in this case it's the loot drop
containing a weapon that perfectly
matches your armor
dead giveaway and total [ __ ] but you
don't care because matching set
also how does this lady just happen to
have a spear made out of one of the
rarest metals in the galaxy
she might as well have a bunch of
vibranium in her basement also also why
does the magistrate think this is a fair
payment for offing a freaking
jedi i know mandalorians are big on best
guard but he's got it all over his body
and this thing is really just a really
strong pointy object
it doesn't even pupe you well these are
the coordinates
the magistrate gave him exact
coordinates if they know where ahsoka is
this precisely how haven't they mounted
an attack on her before now
i know she's a dope-ass jedi but they
could strike while she's asleep or
something
wow the scope has a built-in zoom and
enhanced cliche that can be activated by
the click of a button
okay why does the soga attack mando
immediately maybe because mandalorians
and jedi have been enemies for a long
time okay but she's friendly with bo
katan who's also a mandalorian so what
gives with that
and she must sense the presence of the
child given how powerful she is with the
force so why didn't she ask
any questions before trying to carve the
poor bastard up boca tan sent me
you know her right middle name ra loves
warm weather wearing linen shorts
shuffleboard
some people will spend the next two
minutes of this episode excitedly
waiting for all of our green bean
questions to be answered i however will
ponder this bruce almighty moon and
worry about anyone living on this planet
for much longer
[Music]
yes grogu grogu come
on his name might as well be carl grow
goo can he still wield the force did
that not come up during your psychic
conversation
the jedi order fell a long time ago well
sure but you
are aware that a jedi and his friends
destroyed two death stars after that
right
and luke is presumably training new kids
as you guys speak seriously how does
ahsoka not know anything about what's
going on with her brethren these days
don't they send out some sort of
newsletter via force frequencies across
the galaxy every few months
check your spam folder passing stones i
want to see if they'll listen to you
that would be a first oh shut up mando
the kid obeyed earlier went to his car
seat without rolling his eyes or
anything
also i've never seen a jedi training
session that's so unbelievably boring
even rey's obstacle course from rise of
the skywalker was more entertaining
i cannot train him obvious candidate to
train a recruit with special abilities
refuses to train that recruit cliche and
i'll help you with your problem
if you see to it that grogu is properly
trained
found the side quest phew i was worried
there for a second a mandalorian and a
jedi
they'll never see it coming well sure
until you start attacking them
really what's the benefit of the
surprise collaboration after you enter
the city gates
why bother having this super secure
entrance if you're just gonna nakedly
walk out here at the first sign of
trouble
even winston hid behind his john wick
three while the real fighters did the
real fighting
okay this is some awesome kirosawa
imagery and i appreciate that this
episode wears its influences directly on
the sleeves of its best car armor rather
than obliquely nodding to them
once in off
your bounty hunter failed if that were
the case wouldn't she have brought a
part of the armor that was a little more
impressive maybe like the helmet
or even a cod piece deus ex mandalorica
i'm confused is ahsoka a powerful jedi
or just
batman on a different planet don't get
me wrong this fight is rad as hell but
even if the magistrate is a trained
fighter from the clone wars how's she
standing any chance against a super
powerful jedi in a [ __ ] sword fight
who do you think's gonna win could be
your side
could be my side i mean the dialogue
here is
riveting you guys could be that either
side
could win possibly you and i were a lot
alike
for instance we both like watching
rom-coms and playing candy crush in
addition to ruthlessly killing people
want to get brunch sometime
geez what a dill hole not only should he
know he'd be too slow for mando's draw
what does he think one blaster shot
would do to him does he not see all that
best scar
where is grand admiral thrawn and pause
for fanboy applause
no i'm not applauding because i could
give a flip all about rebels or clone
wars or some canon comic that was
written in 1983 by george lucas's 12
year old second cousin i'm watching the
freaking mandalorian man
i don't want to do homework to be able
to follow along may the force be with
you
is it just me or was ahsoka super not
helpful in this episode and she gave the
kid the name which i guess is fine but
it's also
[ __ ] grogu she attacked mando used
him to get into the village and take
what she wanted from the magistrate then
sent him on yet another sidequest to
figure out baby
purpose she's as useless as a green milk
producing mammary on a male thales iron
oh yeah it's that one mercenary that was
in the first season was kind of cool but
she was killed by the end of the episode
and there have been so many other
important characters introduced since
then so let's run that
back for sure bokeh tan sent me to talk
to you
the best part about having a ubiquitous
helmet on the show's protagonist is that
you can freely play around with adr for
these previously on segments
mando said this line way after this
point in the fight during the last
episode
you know it we know it and most
importantly he knows it
it's called lucasfilm limited so when do
we actually reach the limit
is it soon so you're still going with
grogu then
look sw we're the internet we know
things we basically saved that sonic
movie
give me the ball this is admittedly an
adorable scene but
why is he starting this just now when
they're about to land on tython
it had to be at least a moderately long
trip from corvus right wouldn't mando
start trying this playtime along the way
you can have it just like before i'm
sure it will be completely fine
rehashing the name response ball
training parts of the last episode for
the first four minutes of this episode
since you know there's got to be at
least an
hour of good episode left right when the
nice lady said you had training i just
the nice lady we're gonna find that
place you belong
and they're gonna take real good care of
you it really bugs me how much mando
takes characters at their word ahsoka
didn't really do [ __ ] to help him last
episode except for letting him take the
pointy best car thingy she could have
told him to go anywhere in the galaxy
and his trusting ass would have hopped
on his ship and been on his way despite
this being his only source of
information
i always thought bounty hunters would be
a lot savvier this is tython
what since when is mando going directly
from one place to another without a
detour
sidequest distracting him he didn't get
a distress call from han and chewie
while they were capturing a rathtar or
something along the way
understand he does not wait is this what
they renamed the rise of skywalker while
i wasn't paying attention
looks like that's the magic rock i'm
supposed to take you to down there
and i found it within seconds of
entering the planet's atmosphere lucky
me
ahsoka didn't give me coordinates
landmarks or even general directions as
to which hemisphere this is on but my
trusty old digital battleship computer
gave me the exact location for some
reason
also sure it could be the right one but
if this is a jedi-centric planet there
could be a bunch more of these things
right it's like approaching earth seeing
an apple bees and saying well that's
definitely the correct applebee's
i know i'm channeling auntie edna here
but how does the jetpack not set mando's
cape on fire if you had a jet pack
wouldn't you say ah decay probably too
dangerous
i guess this is it i'll just walk you
across the areola here and set you on
the nipple and we'll do our best to
figure out how any of this works
does this look jedi to you that's racist
maybe there's some kind of control or
something
oh yes nothing funnier than the old guy
tries to find the on button for a rock
routine
i'll assume boba fett picked up the
location tracker signal that gideon's
minions put on the razor crest a few
episodes ago but how this
did he get here so much faster than the
imperial goons they're all traveling in
hyperdrive right
i'll see if i can buy you some time
against the one person you saw exit the
ship
wouldn't it be smarter to just stick
here and defend the rock while the kid's
in sight
seriously why would he even briefly
abandon his sole mission that he's had
for nearly the entire series and is
presumably near the end of
if you want my armor you'll have to peel
it off my dead body
if you want my such and such you'll have
to take it from my dead such and such
cliche
i'm a simple man making his way through
the galaxy
like my father before me call backs the
best guard belongs to the mandalorians
he was looted from us during the purge
well considering all laws are suspended
during that time i think your case is
pretty weak just be glad you weren't
murdered while out trying to shoplift a
candy bar
point that gun away from the kid or i'll
drop you both where you stand
you can make me drop him where he stands
but she's technically already on the
ground so really the best you can do is
slump her where she lays
tell her to drop the gun after you put
down the jet pack
same time stand down and she does well
before he even moves to take off the jet
pack
show doesn't know how to save time
correctly you look like you've just seen
a ghost
nonsense i don't see ezra sabine or
chopper anywhere around here
also of all the things to say about a
helmeted fundamentalist mandalorian
describing his expression is
really one of the most futile endeavors
in my case
boba fett you named your abs of steel
boba fett
and i am now in his service shouldn't
you say you're in his boba
debt or are you like his boba pet does
he take you to the boba vet
when he plays his guitar for you does he
use all the boba frets
say we're offering a fair deal under the
circumstances this deal is a trade-off
of boba's armor for their help in
protecting grogu and it is a pretty good
deal but it was never agreed to by mando
so why did boba and fennick decide to
help him after the events of the episode
boba just takes that [ __ ] later on
despite no acknowledgment that amanda
was cool with it
the fact that mando turns and runs
instead of grabbing his jetpack that's
right at his feet is dumb on so many
levels i'm exhausted even thinking about
it
this is apparently the only parking lot
on this entire planet i guess they don't
charge for the first hour or something
apparently when you need mando taking
out of the battle for a bit you can just
have him make a third attempt at
something that he's already failed at
but this time it knocks him out for a
bit you know for reasons
seriously this is pretty much the rest
of the episode pew pew pew pew pew boba
hits someone amanda tries to break into
the force beam pew
pew pew pew adorable child gets cuffed
what i'm trying to say about this tiny
battle is
imperial skip despite having a clear
view of the field agent may takes out
individual troopers instead of the one
setting up the heavy artillery
we get it stormtroopers suck at aiming
even when they have high caliber
automatic weaponry they are 100 the
keystone cops of the star wars universe
also can you graduate from both the
stormtrooper school of aiming at things
and the rickon stark school of running
away from things
because these guys have a double major
having time to tap your enemy on the
shoulder when there are several others
all around you with guns
speaking of which bringing in anything
except the gun you're already holding
right in your hands and could fire from
a distance instead of running up to the
guy with the sunflower hammer to a gun
fight
yo why does mandel leave his ship wide
open here doesn't he have keyless entry
or some sort of fob that can lock that
[ __ ] down
even if there weren't any intruders here
you'd have to worry about space rodents
getting in the cockpit
guess i won't be needing this anymore i
honestly can't tell if this is ripping
off iron man's weapon or yondu zero from
guardians of the galaxy more but it's
clear that john favreau definitely mixed
up his iconic properties for this scene
we have a day off you do not no one
shook on that
or even verbally recognized the contract
there's no service like fan service like
no service i know everything about it's
unappealing
everything web traffic will allow back
to the ship
back to the ship we've officially
stalled long enough for the episode to
hit 30 minutes
our work here is done the kid but i'm
still not going to grab my jet pack
because climbing up and down this thing
is so fun
have the dark troopers been engaged of
course not we sent two strangely spaced
out battalions of the basic white ones
first
like the script required i actually kind
of dig the dark troopers but why are
they called troopers at all
they're clearly droids i know dark
droids doesn't sound as cool but you
could use another word for dark like
black or
dim yeah that's it dim droids and you
could say cool stuff like
you'll never find a solution for my
persistent dim droids push as hard as
you like my dem droids will never
retreat
they're back hello the empire
boba fett plays the pronoun game so that
finnick has to ask who is back
i guess to be fair he could have been
talking about john wick slim shady or
randy quaid's character from
independence day
also no one in this imperial ship
recognizes nor tries to shoot at this
iconic ship despite it being in full
view of the entire crew
oh come on there's no way this gear
shift ball is still here let alone
easily findable we're already crying
about baby yoda being abducted man no
need to twist the knife
i need you to locate someone in the
prison registry wait is this
everyone in the prison registry
especially in the entire
galaxy she's really gonna scroll through
all these scruffy-looking nerf herders
before she gets the info to narrow it
down
meg's mayfield i know this all happened
a long long time ago and everything but
why does everyone in this universe speak
fluent conversational english but the
text is in our obesh
but these stripes i mean there are rules
i need to follow
they have the kid situational ethics
little known fact both of these
stormtroopers were actually played by
daniel craig
have you ever seen one of these exposing
your dark saber without explicit consent
oh yeah this recap totally reminds me
about that episode in which bando and
breaking bad did the thing with the
stuff and alerted the people that the
whatchamacallit was happening and so the
dude went to the place for that period
of time all caught up 27 seconds of
logos
for a tv show also i just realized
they've been spelling star trek wrong
this whole time
dino cranes i'm sure he's doing some
daily labor but this doesn't look half
bad for a prison you get out into the
open air work on a project and they even
give you proper ppe
hell they could have frozen him in
carbonite so if i were migs i'd be
counting my blessings
inmate three four six six seven please
follow martial duke to transport
somebody gonna tell me what's going on
here well that was easy is this
seriously all it takes to
spring a prisoner seemed like vanda was
setting us up for a [ __ ] heist when
he asked cara this last episode and he
didn't even know she was a marshall
before he got there so what was he gonna
do if she didn't have any official
republic authority
also i get that mayfield is a cautious
guy but he's also been in prison with
i'm assuming only men
and someone who looks like gina carano
just showed up wanting him to follow her
does star wars not understand how boners
work make three four six six seven
i swear to god they refer to migs by his
inmate number so many times in the
beginning of this episode it's like
they're trying to force me to memorize a
phone number and no one remembers phone
numbers anymore
oh cool but we got a glow up but
seriously there were
deep scratches on that armor including
whatever chemical reaction happened
while being partially digested by the
sarlacc
so how do you get this so clean in the
short amount of time he's had it
also howdy replaced the rocket on his
back he used that sucker to blow up the
stormtroopers in the last episode
so it should be disintegrated hell
marshall cobb also used it in his
episode
how does this thing keep getting
restored that was a long time ago all
right but you still know your imperial
clearances and protocols but would they
still be active after being away for a
long time
seriously i was once fired from a fast
food place and couldn't get out the door
because they'd already deleted my
security code in the 30 seconds it took
me to get my
together man this show sure does love it
some ascending ship porn
whoa how things get changed so quickly
and where do they have his clothes
stored did they stop by a goth version
of j crew on the way over here to pick
up some duds
they have his kid the little green guy
and mayfield would care about this
why when he first ran into mando and
grogu he said this
me i was never really into pets yeah i
didn't have the temperament
and after that mando got him arrested
and imprisoned in the scrapyard they
just pulled him from why would he want
to help mando at all
all right but here's the thing i can't
get those coordinates unless they have
access to an internal imperial terminal
look i know he's trying to dial the
accent back a bit but bilper is a
masshole and it's
really odd that there's an obvious
masshole a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away
there's nothing on morak at this point
in the series hasn't mando been proven
wrong about
existing places that aren't supposed to
be there enough times that he wouldn't
even bother with his argument anymore
punch in the coordinates fat fat
who the hell calls him fat is his whole
name too hard to say
are they not on a first name basis after
he pledged his fealty to mando for this
quest
remember how pissed han was when finn
called him solo in the force awakens
i wonder what they were finding in there
looks like rydonia
you can tell that from a blurry hologram
why does any vehicle in this universe
have wheels
it's clear that hover technology exists
and works on even the poorest planets
like
tatooine or jakku wheels would make
everything more treacherous
especially if you're transporting a
highly volatile resource imagine what
the crew and sorcerer would have done if
they'd had access to hover technology
you think they'd be [ __ ] with that
rotten bridge
it's going to be me going in alone or
say goodbye to your little green friend
wait how does he know what i call my
vibrator also moff gideon's had grogu
for
at least a few days now even if it takes
a while to get where he's going they
must have extracted enough blood or
stool or whatever the hell they need
from him along the way to do their evil
i'm just saying mando should have been
moving much faster from the jump if he
thinks he's actually going to rescue the
kid
i'm not saying kara couldn't handle her
own against these two guys but armando
and mayfield not going to jump down and
at least
see if she needs any assistance also
more helmet punching
i don't care if these aren't best car
they should be at least somewhat
protective right
otherwise why the heck are they wearing
them just make sure you take out the
rooftop gunners
hey why does bando sound the exact same
in this helmet as his regular one
are the voice modulators the same seems
like there'd be at least a slight tonal
disparity
what's going on here
show the science we need to know the
steps mayfield takes to understand the
mechanics of this vehicle and
i assure you we do not
i'm taking this thing off i can't see
anything
first off if mix can't see anything how
does anyone see anything out of one of
those helmets
also mix leaves this off for the rest of
the episode and even though he's
ex-imperial and stuff troopers are
supposed to wear their helmets right
show could not make it more obvious that
they need to easily identify these two
that are dressed in identical uniforms
i don't know how you people wear those
things that's racist and by you people i
do mean mandalorians
still racist don't worry about the
rhydonium
as long as you drive steady you'll get
us to the refinery
wages of mandalorians also how the heck
does mando know that
also also when did star wars become
obsessed with fuel sources
last jedi solo a star wars story now
this unobtainium crap
why do we care about the fuel
oh yeah that's definitely necessary
there's no way these [ __ ] can see
this giant transport coming their way
also hey those are villagers on this
planet human even
yet mando confidently explained there
was nothing on this planet a few minutes
ago despite it being habitable and
honestly
quite pleasant i'm a survivor just like
you another we're not so different you
and me cliche
didn't we just get this in the michael
bean standoff a few episodes ago
what the hell's that if that monitor was
right in mando's line of sight this
whole time how did he not see the
pirates until they already jumped on the
ship
furthermore if they heard the single
pirate jump on this clearly how did the
real stormtroopers not hear three of
these idiots jump on the roof just a few
moments ago
are you seriously shooting a blaster
near rydonia mayfield would be excellent
tv sense
you know these are supposed to be
pirates which means they're looking for
booty right
so why are they just straight destroying
the juggernauts instead of taking the
rhidonium or whatever else is valuable
cargo what do they get out of just
blowing this stuff
up mayfield pick it up drive faster and
i'm sure migs can hear this while
driving rapidly down a dirt road while
inside the cab in the middle of a pirate
attack
oh you say that there are comms in the
helmets of these trooper uniforms well
migz isn't wearing his so there this is
the third round of not pirates that
manda will have to fend off
we know mano isn't going to blow up or
die here which is to say this battle
goes on for all the some time
yeah totally time to celebrate since
these tie fighters are nowhere
close to hitting the pirates on the
initial view blast mix was worried about
mando's blaster fire a few seconds ago
but he's all whining roses when the
freaking heavy artillery is opening fire
at the transport carrying very unstable
cargo
yeah don't pay any attention to the
thermal detonator that was thrown just
keep moving towards it and firing away
[ __ ] storm troopers i can't do it
okay we gotta fill board i'm sorry
niggs is all worried about being
recognized by this butthole but what's
the big deal
even if he did recognize him as a field
operative in a previous campaign
it was for the empire right so he'd
either get glad-handed or receive a nod
of welcome at the most
also he went in there showed his face
and is now acting
super cagey if dude didn't recognize him
before he'd be much more suspicious now
helmet hair
facial scan complete what
why would mando's facial scan grant him
access to classified imperial data
also if this was going to be the case
then why did they need mayfeld in the
first place they could have just
questioned him about what to do back at
the scrap yard and been on their way
also also the heck is up with that
mustache why even bother with a mustache
if you're gonna wear the helmet all the
live long day you're telling me he
manscapes this diligently but refuses to
show that magnificent lip rug
you're the tank troopers that delivered
the shimmer to redonium
how does this dude know that the
shipment was delivered he's been sitting
here with his buddy drinking in the mess
hall
and they just got here before walking
straight into the room
how about a toast to operation cinder
mix was scared to death just a few
seconds ago about this dude recognizing
him but now that he knows he's not going
to be recognized his balls drop and he
decides to provoke this dill hole
instead of having his drink and getting
the crap out of there
once who died was it good for them i
have to say this scene really makes as
much sense as star-lord punching thanos
in the face in infinity war which
is to say it makes no sense but i have
to give it to bill burr for this
performance the guy has range he's only
getting more and more
opportunities so i guess i should remove
a sin for this hang on i
just said the scene makes no sense add
five more for even making me think about
taking one away
i never saw your face miggs and
therefore the show has time for this
you get the coordinates on loft gideon
we did
what's our next move i don't know but
it's definitely not going straight to
the coordinates and rescuing the kid
because
that plan has a disturbing lack of side
quests involved soon
he will be back with me letting your
enemy know you're coming for them cliche
go to the planet typhon oh great thanks
to this recap we can recall how
unhelpful ahsoka's been in this entire
series anne is only there so she can set
herself up a spin-off
it's exactly like nicki minaj showing up
to steal kanye's monster track with her
verse knowing that she's just creating
pub for the eventual album pink friday
yep i just compared to sokatano to nicki
minaj there aren't many jedi left
that's okay with advanced technology no
jedi can ever really die and in a pinch
we can sort of copy-paste their face on
a new body for maximum impact
not this show would ever do anything
like that why is boba fett even shooting
at them right now
they definitely want dr pershing alive
so what if they accidentally destroy him
and his ship
i'll tell you what would happen the
creation of the greatest gif ever of
boba fett performing an epic face palm
do you ever wonder what massive light
source illuminates the spaceship porn
yeah me either coms are down i'm sorry
sir we've established in this series
that everyone speaks an american accent
for some reason
i think you're looking for the jj abrams
trilogy it's right down the hall
so the ion cannon wiped out some comms
but
not the very specific comms needed to
hear this announcement
neat i don't have a death wish do you a
surprising admission for a person who in
mere moments will brutally goad zena
with vile threats until she blasts him
is he shocked horrified impressed horny
the world may never know wait wait i
know this one two mandalorians walk into
a bar the bartender turns to the first
one and says
why the long face and the second one
says don't test us
and then the bartender says you mean man
don't test us
and then they kill him also character
walks into a saloon and everyone stops
turns and stares cliche
oh hey it's two of the most famous and
dangerous mandalorian warriors in the
galaxy
and amanda was able to locate them in
record time despite having no clue that
they existed until a few episodes ago
they took the child who moth gideon
you'll never find him bo katan
rightfully states that finding grogu
will be impossible
and then the scene goes off-roading into
a bounty hunter pissing match for a few
minutes
and when we finally veer back to the
plot mando reveals he has
moff's coordinates and my point is why
doesn't he say this here when it's
relevant to their immediate conversation
you won't find him actually i have the
coordinates let's go
and see so
it's a go so why throw the bow no to
mando in the flow show
you are a disgrace to your armor the
heck is that bo katan's ass about boba
fett
just a few episodes ago she was all
kumbaya about there being different
types of mandalorians but she's going
hard at boba for no reason other than
his voice and even though the
stormtrooper clones were based off
django
ain't none of them sound anything like
him mandalorians have been in exile from
our home world for far too long
expositional motivation exposivation i
will kill them off and retake what is
rightfully mine
and that is all you need to know or not
know for now
there's plenty of time to cover any
incredibly specific details about the
importance of how i need to kill him and
take the weapon but i think reckless
secrecy is a supremely good idea for
right now
what's up with pershing's indoor
sunglasses here are those prescription
or is he just cory harding everyone in
an attempt to look cool
these are third generation design they
are no longer suits
they didn't even threaten pershing or
even ask for his opinion this motor
scuffer is just spouting off about the
ship's logistics like he's under some
sort of truth serum or something
where they biv whacked good lord that is
a really personal question have you no
shame
koska fennec dune myself disembarked
with maximum initiative
phew good to know bo katan's setting her
phaser to maximum initiative i'd hate to
see how this plan would go down if she
dialed that
back to like i don't know six and a half
here take his coat cylinder and seal off
their holding bay
no need to talk about which buttons to
press on the panel to ensure that the
holding bay doors actually close
the power of the doohickey device is all
you need
requesting emergency docking they're
doing a good job pretending it's an
emergency but the imps
also know that this is the shuttle
that's bringing back the super important
pershing so how do they not
immediately realize something's up when
a female voice is coming from a ship
that was previously piloted by two dudes
somewhere there's a reddit thread
begging to see how the tie fighters are
launched
this ends for you and there goes boba
fett i understand he's not part of the
ship takeover but don't you think the
plan could have included him doing a bit
more to help
oh yeah my favorite parts of star wars
properties are the extended blurry
sequences of the protagonist easily
offing these super killable
stormtroopers
dude activating the dim droids also
activates some of the gnarliest
industrial music i've heard since nine
inch nails pretty hate machine
someone said this scene needs charging
station wiggle tubes that spew snow and
fog
those people were wrong she totally
kicked that dude's ass before actually
killing him what was the point
fenix a cold mudder scuffer man are we
really rooting for her
holy moly when did blaster start jamming
and running out of ammo like it did in
the last episode those things never seem
to malfunction in the hands of
stormtroopers except for
you know when they try to aim at
something unwelcome dimdroid flareups
if the dim birds got this close to
breaking the glass don't you think the
sudden vacuum of space would be enough
to finish the job and suck mando out
along with them
[Music]
this universe has more nonsensical curse
words than the fork in good place
okay look an all-female takeover of this
ship is the perfect
authentic antithesis to the bull shirt
that marvel's stuffed down our throats
in in-game and it deserves to send off
where's gideon great question and
considering the importance of your quest
you should probably leave the bridge to
go look for him i'd start in the one
place you know he holds a super
important tiny prisoner but hey you can
just hang out here until the plot
complexes things quite a bit for you
later
what could these shackles do for this
padawan's jedi abilities
sure you see jedi use their hands when
they force push things around and stuff
but he can do all that with his mind
right
are the hand movements essential like
james mcavoy touching his temple to read
minds in the newer x-men movies
drop the blaster but not the best car
poke pole the jet pack or flamethrower
those are okay where is this going well
given the recent announcements in the
post-credits stinger i've heard is at
the end of this episode i'm gonna say
take care of one three seven uh divide
by pi
about 47 spin-offs from the two seasons
of this show i'm guessing
that bokeh tan and her boarding party
have arrived at the bridge
you know this scene would be far more
interesting if he hadn't just said
assume that i know everything but now
he's all
i'm guessing so do you know anything or
not are you scary
you see she wants this
i guess i'm kind of immune to the
villain exposits vital information right
before the final fight cliche at this
point but
when it's information that we already
know it deserves an extra five sins
whoever wields this sword has the right
to lay claim
to the mandalorian throne well that's
just dumb
what if a wampa picked it up and swung
it around does that mean the wampa would
lead the mandalorians is this another
spin-off
a young wampa wins the dark saber in
battle but this time it's a dance battle
wamp the yard coming to disney plus fall
2021
man gideon just keeps whacking away
despite seeing no damage being done to
mando's suit
he knows that's best car right poketon's
sole mission depends on her defeating
gideon so
why is she staring out the window like
she's looking for the next galactic gas
station for a quick piss and greasy
snack
why don't you kill him now and take it
is moth getting an empire loyalist
or a merry prankster seems like he's
more amused that he just got his ass
handed to him instead of figuring out a
way to turn the tides in battle
it must be won in battle rules
oh no the mark tens have invaded the
ship this is terrible news how will they
ever do
you're about to face off with the dark
troopers you said dem droid's wrong
you had your hands full with one really
it took man to less than a freaking
minute to take care of that one and now
he knows how they work here's an idea
grab a cylinder pull a lever and
jettison them into space again but this
time aim the big starship guns at them
boom bam done i am so good at star wars
bad guy is suddenly armed and unwatched
despite being incredibly dangerous and
the focus of all the heroes hatred up
until now
cliche mando has his blaster out here
even though he knows the only thing that
worked last time was the best car spear
seriously i know we're all excited about
this finale but there's a lot of weird
[ __ ] near the end of this sucker
the sound of this alarm seems to wait is
that an x-wing that's an x-wing what is
groga sensing
who's on the screen who's in the robe is
it they have a lightsaber that is a
lightsaber that is a saber of light
the light is sabering that is a green
light saber look at him go oh
this is in the force push oh and the
spin oh he cut that thing right in half
what is
he has a gloved hand
the force pushed the leg chop he chopped
off his head
he's going into the elevator he's coming
up why is this elevator ride taking
forever
open the elevator i need to see
show me here it comes yes
get him get him and then kill him and
then kill him
and then just spin around and force push
and kill and slice and lightsaber and
the gloved hand and it's green and a
bare hand one gloved hand and i think i
know who this
is there's only one person it could be
show me your face it's got to be almost
there die
it's luke's guy
girl
[Music]
well that was one of the most satisfying
fan games ever but
like most chasms it's being immediately
followed by guilt and shame
maybe i should rewind it watch again and
let my proper dark side drive
all right here we go why did they stop
why indeed are you telling me the
droids are force sensitive now and can
tell a jedi's on board
allowing an infant to watch a violent
show also allowing an infant to watch tv
far
too closely that's how you develop poor
vision return of the red eye
seriously those dim holes have their
backs to you why would you wait for this
jedi to come out and do all the heavy
lifting when you have a distinct
advantage to take these droids out
sorry i can't buy into that you can do
all this [ __ ] with a big old robe on no
matter how badass it may be
think about it in every jedi fight scene
the first thing they do is drop the robe
even ahsoka did it earlier in the season
and she's definitely a jedi are you a
jedi
i'd remove all the sins from this entire
season if luke's response was something
like
does a jedi [ __ ] in the woods i mean why
can't amanda go with the jedi
i mean this is the way
right can't they just stay together with
creepy flesh puppet luke
i'll just point out that groggs wasn't
interested in going with luke until the
sudden convenient r2 electronic showed
up to distract him from his emotions
john favreau can simply not contain his
lust for promotional post-credit
sequences damn it
finnick just walked right over to that
trap door and even if they haven't
replaced the rancor that's still not an
optimal spot to stand
as bobo well knows boba the hutt
what is your quest
you must be crazy yeah maybe you're
right
kill him finish him easy with that face
on me
oops a wet one i hope i didn't
stain my underwear you're making a
terrible mistake i'm not gonna let you
make come on guys
nobody wants this we're supposed to be
professionals
surprise sydney
you
good people who have traveled from
villages near and far
lend me your ears that's disgusting
[Music]
why are my drippings with ghoul pan down
from the twin sons
of tatooine after a beat the gloved
mandalorian armor gauntlet of boba fett
grabs onto the sand outside the sarlacc
pit and we realize
uh that he survived his fall uh during
the battle
at jabba's uh palace ship
dusty everyone knows one down
don't drink any more of that boba it can
clog up your intestines
i guess those are just stories for
children
girl the shade the shade
you've been captain of the black power
for 13 years
technically i was only chem for two
years then i was viciously mutated upon
then you would have pooled captain but
it cut to none the lace
you killed my brother prepare to die
now i'm gonna kill your pet
and your little dog too happy birthday
hey i said my first words i am
a good that's right no
now that's the button that will kill
everyone show me the red wire
red wire blue wire black is usually the
ground
so much pressure
[Music]
you son of a [ __ ] i'll get my best
people on it
we have top men working on it right now
who top
men i can't be happy here knowing that
there's
people out there who have nothing
what would you have wakanda do about it
i should have here watched empire and
jedi last week and ever since we've been
trying to do the jedi mind trick
attention earthlings take me to your
dealer
they fly now
[Music]
but let me assure you this my presence
will be
ornamental you will find me a respectful
quiet passive observer
[Music]
hello hello who is it
it is king arthur whose castle is this
this is the castle of my master guide
help us help me i have a proposition
that may interest you
suppose i were to offer you one million
dollars
you want the moon just say the word and
i'll throw a lasso around and pull it
down
[Music]
we'll handle this
[Applause]
why johnny ringo
you look like somebody just walked over
your grave
i didn't finish the job no
but sometimes in the heat of the moment
it's forgivable to go ask to mouth shall
not forget you
how brave you are to be alone in the
woods
think ferret language i'll see if i can
buy you some time
can you please hurry up i'm trying to
use the
phone you were dead your friend here is
only
mostly dead there's a big difference
between
mostly dead and all that you couldn't
handle my midriff
okay i'm gonna protect you okay i'm
going take off
see ya
dang it the damage is not too bad as
long as the foundations are still strong
we can rebuild this place it will become
a haven for all peoples and aliens of
the
universe you're not ready to play with
such things you'll shoot your eye out
kid
you just took one in the jugular man
this isn't so bad huh
making bucks getting exercise
working outside
what did migs say to you multiple migs
in the next cell
he said i can smell your i see
i myself cannot you going to tell me
where you're taking me
some lovely filth down here i'm not
going to need long inside so once i get
the coordinates you guys got to get me
the hell out of there
you get to the roof i'll drop in and
pull you out there's a plan in
everything kid
and i love it when a plan comes together
i wish i could say i look good on you
but i'd be lying so you're telling me
there's a chance
but you couldn't drive of course i can
drive why does everyone say that
i used to drive i don't know how you
people wear those things
what do you mean you people
[Music]
what's your name officer my name is jeff
there's a special run in hell reserved
for people who waste good scotch
seeing as i may be rapping in the door
momentarily i must say
damn good stuff sir
i regret nothing soon
he will be back with me i will look for
you
i will find you and i will kill you
scotty put the ship's faces on stun
you want to know what else i saw i
watched jane die
it's terrible i'm gonna have permanent
hearing damage let me see it
i don't bargain
[Music]
all right easy save it for the imps
oh yeah just like it nobody backing down
nothing
if we had shown half that spine to the
empire we would have never lost our
planet
sorry you see what i mean i just get
carried away no
no
where is this going this
is where it's going all up in yes
megatron
do you yield
looking down someone you have i would
say